[Music]
I I I I you know I was telling Lee two
weeks ago I went to Miami and as I'm
walking the second show Friday night a
girl makes sure she comes to the thing
she's sitting at the table right where I
was walking
out and this girl turns around and comes
right to the thing and grabs me and she
looks at me and I look at her she kind
of looks familiar but not really I look
at her she goes hi meet my husband and
she goes Joey and I were friends years
ago we went out for a drink one night
after a comedy show and she looked at me
and winked oh and I looked at her and it
was like uh I felt like somebody in the
The Devil's Advocate that movie when he
whenever C the chick would what's her
name chariss Theon would talk they turn
into a devil and she go that was me that
night when I saw and I remember the
night where this chick took me home with
the chubby chick this chick was banging
fake tits she said she dated an David
Lee Roth she had pictures of David Lee
Roth I mean the [__] was hot and we
went back to house I had dead dick I
couldn't come I couldn't my dick was
small it was embarrassing but then I
never forget that these two girls in
front of me I'm sitting there watching
Conan O'Brien make him believe like I'm
not even seeing this at this point
that's the other thing at that point
when I would do
Coke [__] would be second I was like
those mice in the [__] cage yeah that
you know they're trying to feed him
they're trying to give him like [__]
cheeseburger and and fingers and [__]
but they rather snort the coke that was
me and I remember them two chicks had a
big black dildo like a big black with
two heads on it and one one would [__]
the one side and one would [__] the and
they're doing this in front of me
moaning banging this thing and I'm just
sitting there watching Conan O'Brien
like they're not even in the [__]
room yeah and then and then it just
turned into a nightmare the chubby chick
wanted me to [__] I had dead dick I
tried to whack off I ended up eating the
[__] good-looking one the chubby
chick left the good-looking one had a
period it was just a night from hell but
then the me and the good-looking one
hooked up the rest of the week yeah and
then on Sunday she goes there's
something I got to tell you I'm getting
married in two weeks wow so today when
you go home don't ever call my number
again and it was [__] traumatizing I
was in love with her but I couldn't
believe that you know I'm a Catholic I
couldn't believe this chick was [__]
going to get married yeah and we're
[__] did you feel like you should
maybe do her husband a favor and go tell
him that he's about to step in [__] [__]
no he probably knew cuz he was he was
some type of weatherman so he got up
early so he they had a deal they
wouldn't see each other during the week
yeah so she was out she her father own
like some how import dealership or
something this girl had a Mercedes an
Audi she lived in the top floor of a
building she had Coke she had a rack
with just Don peran bottles in the
[__] rack she was spoiled Rich you
know she was spoiled rotten so she would
just go out every night and do blow I
remember she paid for the blow that
night I didn't this was a high-profile
trainer this is like this is yeah but
it's weird how I sit back and go I'm not
even a good-looking guy I had no money
that nighte I was a feature act I was
probably making $550 a week 300 of it
went to a plane ticket yeah 200 went to
a plane ticket you know they didn't give
you a plane ticket back then as a
feature I had no money I had no Mercedes
I had no clothes I was just living on
the road week to week and this girl took
me home for a week we went to eat all
the fine restaurants she picked up every
[__] tab and she was younger than I
was she was maybe if I was 35 maybe she
was
probably 27 yeah you know it was
embarrassing what town was this this is
Miami the only Town [__] like that
happens yeah you know well it happens
other places but it's just amazing that
you could be I when I left New Jersey
Jersey I was a criminal but I wasn't a
sex deviant so I didn't know about all
these sex things like I really didn't
know I thought people just [__] and
ate ass then I find out people get tied
up and they put balls in their mouths
and yeah you know whip them and throw
darts at them I didn't know that that
girl I dated one day said to me I don't
know if you know this the guy that a guy
put me through college and I'm like what
are you talking about and she goes I
used to have a sugar daddy for six years
he still sends me money six years he put
her through school damn and he would put
her to school pay her bills College
everything and once a week she' have to
come over there and just go [__] off
on his dick yeah he would bring other
hookers over and his whole thing was to
see her eat another hooker and him would
jerk off on her back I mean and she
would tell me these stories and my head
would want to [__] my soul would want to
cry yeah I never been involved in
nothing like that I never two on one I
never I did one threesome yeah I think
I'd be too embarrassed to do a [__]
threesome what about you you ever do a
threesome you dirty no but like I like I
can imagine how like a good-looking girl
would do that that have a guy offered
you to pay especially now when college
is going to cost you 200 Grand not on
top of krie did that oh I know I got a I
got a buddy who's he's got a lot of Mill
you know billionaire friends and they've
all got chicks set up and one in Miami
one in New York one in LA and they come
to town and they buy him an apartment
they release him a car they throw him
some money every month and they come to
town and it's like they drop whatever
they're doing that's the deal your mine
for that week could be two weeks and
then I may not see again for 6 months
but for that time you're going to be my
dirty dog and you're going to walk not
only that you're going to walk in a
restaurants the money I gave you means
you got some decent clothes to wear so
that I can show up with you and that's
their deal that's the deal and it goes
on like you said six years you know he
says these things go on for 10 years
women that are consistently living a
life where they build into it that
they're a prostitute for a little bit of
time and the rest of the time they are
they're going to college or they're
that's that's her right there was he you
got a neighbor I don't know we never do
them at this time so and so uh yeah and
the rest of the time they're they're
married or maybe they've got uh a
startup business they're trying to get
going but if this guy's good for you
know 50 Grand a year and taking care of
all their expenses they're like well you
know if I think it's everybody's got a
relationship to their body you know like
women either feel protective of their
body and it's like their soul and their
body are one
or it's like my body is this thing that
I I don't really care about if a guy
wants to get something from it he can
and I'll gladly take money for it and
like porn stars like they don't have any
attachment to their bodies they can let
the things happen to their bodies and it
doesn't affect them so then you get the
Irish Irish girls who uh you just look
at them and they got to go
confess I'm an Irish girl type of guy
yeah since day one I ended up with an
Irish girl I got an Irish daughter right
I I love love Irish girls that's my
alltime [__] favorite I got an Irish
one well mine's half Irish half Jewish I
love it oh there you go Lee H you got a
steak in this this I can't date I mean
I'm surprised you dat it an Irish woman
cuz I can't date Jews because you're
full Irish 100% it's just it's too it
reminds me too much of my mother yeah so
I just can't I mean is that why you
didn't date a like like when I started
dating a Hispanic girl you told me like
right off like they're crazy like I
won't even do Fu crazy they're crazy but
I'm crazy that's why it didn't work for
me yeah a Hispanic girl for it to really
work like I see a lot of Jews go for
Hispanic chicks and I see when a white
guy dates a his Spanish chick it tames
them it balances them off yeah when you
have two fire people it doesn't work
right I went through that one time with
a Spanish girl and that was it two
Spanish girls one for about a year and
one for like eight months and it was
horrible I was always in an argument I
was always tensed up when I walked in
the door I don't want to be tensed up I
don't want to be tensed up at all when I
walk in my house in the back of your
mind you always think your first [__]
is going to be this [__] thing with
angels and and birds are getting shot
out into the sky you hear voices that
never did that [__] never happened for
me you know it was like my first [__]
was just the opposite girl Linda and she
was uh great girl but she'd been she'd
been around town you know she was
confident big tits she called him pride
and joy and she said to me for my 16th
birthday she was going to give me the
best [__] I would ever have in my
life and she came over my house parents
were out it's April it's a nice spring
day I remember the windows open little
breeze coming in Linda comes up to my
room and she takes my pants down herself
I try to take them off she stops me she
takes them off then she takes the
underwear off and then she works it and
I mean she's I didn't know that a
[__] included ball licking that that
was an option I didn't know that it
circled I didn't know that there was two
hands could be cranked on the bass a
decent size and uh and she worked it and
there was eye contact there was intent
eye contact throughout checking in she
wanted to know how I was doing every
second I'd be so [__] embarrassed oh
it was
unbelievable postcoidal I cuddled with
her after the
[__] and I feel for you Joey that
that that had to be your first [__] I
got to ask you something where is she
today she has kids and she lives a
couple Towns over from where we grew up
I think she did well I think she married
well you still keeping touch with time
to time send her a little
Facebook it's always good to hit one of
those freaks on Facebook and give them
like a little reminder yeah I have one
I'm working now not because I want to
sleep or or nothing just because she was
such a Savage and such an animal yeah
and now she's got a kid but I want to
remind her that she's such an animal
so I do I post this New Jersey first of
all the last time I had seen this girl
was when Doug floody threw the touchdown
okay and it was just a horror show I
robbed Lou Donado at this time she was
Louis boss she was Louis uh what is a
nanny and I saw at corkies and this
[__] had a body they called her Lor
Jack because they said you know those
days she's got the Jack yeah everybody
said she had some ACDC wrote a song call
she's got the jack which implied she had
like AIDS not AIDS at that time but like
garia Gia chyia and all that no there
wasn't even chyia in 79 in 79 it was
just syphilis and something came out of
your dick yeah that's it all of a sudden
over the years they've added all these
dimensions and names to throw you off it
all started with funk the head of your
dick swells up blood comes out you know
what I'm saying your nuts are purple you
go crazy good ones you go crazy oh my
God you sit there and go what did I [__]
what type of animal did I [__] what
planet is she from yeah and I'll tell
you something knock on wood I can be
honest on this show it never happened to
me I just had shut up I had crabs I've
gotten crabs and then I was [__]
around with these dirty college girls
when you mess around with college girls
bro you always when to get something fo
[__] the whole campus yeah you get
foot fungus something I had this I had
this little leakage coming out of my
helmet yeah and then I noticed that both
of them like when I was sleeping with
one for a while and then she moved then
I started sleeping with the other one
both of them had this like white leakage
from their little monkey it was Chia but
I wasn't going to embarrass him and tell
him I just get white didn't kept eating
that ass you know me this got nothing to
do with Uncle Joey it's like finding a
hair in your hamburger get rid of it
keep eating that [__] you know people
send the hamburger back come on before
you send them hamburger back think back
of how many [__] you licked right or
wrong you ever get these [__]
there was hair in my food come here let
me talk to you about you take the hair
out and you proceed you're going to send
the sandwich back back and now they're
going to spit in it you know cuz that's
what you do when somebody there has a
hair in your food what's wrong with hair
let me put a [__] Co knot from
Tuesday in that [__] wait till
you crunch into that and think it's a
grape I got a hemorrhoid oh you I'm
going to rub the Hemorrhoid on your
French fries not even you take you
squeeze the Hemorrhoid you get that
hemorrhoid juice it's like that black
[__] T it comes out they think it's
ramade sauce these [__] jerk [__]
gentiles that [__] drives me crazy when
people act like that oh well you know
stop yeah be [__] [__] no and I I
don't even like the guy that uh has them
pour a half a glass of wine pour the
[__] wine and drink the wine what
what are you going to drink you're going
to take a sip from half a glass and
swish it around and then say no Caesar
wants you Caesar wants you to bring
forth another glass of [__] you I got to
tell you guys you know what my mom
bought some wine this week she's out for
Thanksgiving she went to Ralph's and
bought bought some wine and next night I
come home and I go mom what do you get
five ice cubes in your wine for she goes
it's [__] wine and it's like buy another
[__] bottle of wine she's like nah
finish this one Club W but here's the
crazy thing that
culture never was sold to me okay Lee
you're a very young man uh my man Irish
is younger than I am I came from a
culture Family Affair courtship of 's
Father uh Room
combat you know all those shows when men
had a conversation in the 60s and 70s in
the early late 60s and 70s on television
on CBS NBC or CB or what ABC when three
two men had a
conversation there was always a bottle
on a table with no label on it there was
a bucket with ice cubes with PR and as
soon as two men walked in a room what
are we going to do about the Diaz
situation well I the first thing I did
in this late 60s and early 70s was to
turn around okay without even eye
contact without offering you didn't even
offer in this time in the United States
you turned around you took two glasses
you put a nice cube in each right on TV
while the camera was rolling and he was
saying his stupid [__] lines about
how the world's going to end and if the
Russians don't go out to the fallout
shelter and they'd always pour from a
bottle which you assume was whiskey
correct always do you remember this as a
Young Man something brown and they gave
to everybody and everybody they they
didn't go cheers or salute or they just
drank it and they discussed their
situation and throughout the show
drinking was always acceptable yeah as a
young man for for me for me that made my
dick hard my mom had a bar you know what
next week when I go down there I'm going
to get a [__] drink with an ice cube
and how old are you at this point five
six you know me dog it looks cool I
understand it looks [__] tremendously
cool what kid doesn't get what kid
doesn't look at that and go I can't wait
to be [__] 18 to do that to drink a
[__] shot I remember being a kid we
had these shrimp cocktail glasses my
parents would buy a sixpack of shrimp
cocktails from from the right remember
those youh them SC to you wash them out
you keep the glasses and it's about the
size of a of a scotch glass so I
remember me and my brothers just we put
one Ice Cube in we put some Coca-Cola on
top and we'd walk around the house like
we were in [__] mad
man no [__] sipping it sipping it you
know and then we'd roll up pieces of Pap
my parents my dad smoke three and a half
packs a day we'd roll up pieces of paper
we dangle them out of our mouths and we
drink Coke with an ice cube there you go
America so you were I don't know it was
like alcoholism was acceptable okay
whatever now my mom had a bar I got
drunk one time [__] my pants they found
me in a closet that was the end of my
alcoholism career did you know that that
was it that was it my mom had a thing
before she' go to bed she do a little
shot of wine I scul the [__] red
Italian wine once she fell asleep I went
I drank the whole bottle of wine my mom
got up host Antonio H Antonio no host
Antonio she di 911 the cops came they
found me in the closet puked [__] all
over the place how old were you four
five that was the end of my alcoholism
career right that's it that's it no more
sh everything there was sh on my feet
they had to put me in the tub I slept
for two days you know it's always been a
[__] disaster and that was it and you
never drank since no I I've tried I
[__] tried I've tried what was that
movie with oh um okay the Blake Lively
that broad played it to the [__] Hilt
just a dirty Irish girl at the bar that
goes out every night for a good time I
love those girls yeah I love the only
makeup is just some you're not going to
[__] tell them not to go out every
night yeah that's going to stop right
there cuz they'll knock the [__] out of
you you just take them home three nights
a week and you have a great time with
them they puke they always puke after
you give them a stabbing right then you
got to kiss them and [__] you don't give
a [__] by that point you did what you
had to do and [__] they wake up what
happened I don't know what happened they
wake up you're down at the bottom of the
bed licking their dirty feet oh loving
every [__] minute I don't toes I
don't lick toes that's disgusting and
but I like the dirty feet but once we
get into bed you got to wash those
I don't I can't have those dirty Hoops
on my bed and [__] do you wash their
feet I got a f no no no what am I
jesus the I got a fun I told myself I'm
walking around with duct tape on and
[__] sometimes I get radio waves I'm
like a [__] antenna now with my
little fungi [__] toe got to get
those those sneakers with the toes cut
out of this fungi toe is killing me
because like for 6 months it'll just
throb at night the fungi comes alive th
hurts yeah I thought it was just growing
again this weekend I go in the tub and I
just sit there for like I only do it in
hotels I bring the heavy duty artillery
to the hotels and [__] the the
industrial nail cutters and the [__] you
clean the fungi so I go in the tub I
soak that [__] I cut those Nails I take
them and I sniff them real
good do you save it for after the show I
leave him for the m i put a 20 right on
top of there you go have a party [__]
sucker she comes in the room she L at
the couch there's a thousand little
[__] fungi Nails everywhere all
different colors green purple they're
like the gay
flag they cut holes in the [__]
cushions J so sharp oh my God sometimes
I cut them and poke my wife with them I
was telling I was just pokeing and she
go what the [__] is that it's a fungi
nail keep it up it's like a snake
tooth she's going to get like an
infection what's on theun I'll take this
to a concert I'll stab like 18 people 16
will start scratching within minutes
[__] that's what I should do take a
fungi nail out and do a show of me
stabbing people with my fungi nail can I
stab you with my fun nail
see got someone to eat it oh that's it
I'm going to let them grow sell it after
the show I used to date this girl she
grew up she used to grew up in a cult
and one of the jobs she had to do was
cut the [__] Master's nails and I go
what do you mean and she goes they grew
over his toe so once a week we'd have to
go upstairs he weighed like 500
lb they all had to suck his dick no [__]
he [__] all their moms it's a horrible
Story how old was she 14 yeah she
basically grew up in that [__] cult
and she still talks to her parents I
would [__] chiping with my brothers
and having them hit by a truck yeah
right you know what I'm saying you dirty
[__] you want to be Freaks and
move into a cult do it on your own time
leave me with my aunt who goes to church
on Sundays you know you going to take me
with you to some fat [__] house he's
going to [__] us all in the
ass clipping toenail and the father's
sleeping at night while everybody's
getting [__] including his wife
because they had seven kids but three of
them belong to the cult leader oh oh no
[__] but they took them with them and
sold them as their own and when you see
the whole family together sold them like
you know they sold them the story that
they were parents you're crazy we your
dad so four kids have a lot of teeth and
the other three kids are just sitting
there [__] with regular [__]
Smiles you know what I'm saying and
nobody's smiling everybody's frowning
yeah cuz everybody's confused why does
he have blonde
hair what a shame in this country oh my
God the Cults it's part of it seems
appealing to me at this point you know
to start a cult I just need to come up
with some crazy [__] you know like I
think I I think I would run a good cult
what qualify it as a cult you can't
leave oh okay oh [__] you can't oh no
yeah no you got to stick around but I
think that uh I think I I wouldn't [__]
the girls I'd let everybody get laid you
know and I think we we'd raise some
money but uh I wouldn't hog it spread it
around let everybody have some fun but
get a [__] get some land build some
cabins lot of nudity good music lot of
doors the doors the doors that's what we
had on tonight LA Woman what if I'm phal
album it's great album that really is a
good [__] album man yeah they
produced good albums in the studio let
me tell you something growing up that
album irritated me to no
end my mom wouldn't listen to the whole
album she just listened to LA Woman over
and over and over LA Woman is how I
learn how to speak SP English in a way
oh yeah cuz she'd play it and make me
dance for The Other Women in the room
like they play cards and [__] my Mom
would put on La woman that sounds like a
cult but it wasn't a cult it was a bunch
of crazy CU women playing cards and snor
and blow in in the
70s and uh it's crazy how when I was 13
I picked up the album on my own and I
would play it my mom's like I thought
you didn't like this [__] I go no I
hated it because you tell me how hot Jim
Morrison was yeah when you're [__]
five you don't want to hear about a hot
guy and my mom would say someday I'm
going to meet Jim Morrison and just eat
him in Spanish she would
say and I would go what the [__] are you
talking about wow you know Cuban women
loved Steve
McQueen and Jim Morrison they loved Rock
Hudson until they found out he was gay
yeah not even in' 85 they knew in the
60s rock was gay in the 50s when he
would go to Cuba that's where he would
go to escape to be gay cuz you could be
gay in Cuba in the 50s you were a
celebrity so I could bring Joe [__] is my
assistant yeah get two rooms but he's
not there to sleep in that room uhhuh
he's over in the room with me me rubbing
my [__] fungi toenail and sucking my
toe and sucking my balls and you know
what I'm saying his tongue would be my
Beday yeah yeah and he's making eye
contact he has you know that's how Rock
Hudson I remember when I was a kid my
mom used to always tell me that that
Rock Hudson was gay yeah and I would go
[__] how do you know that and when I
got older like two years before she died
she goes how do I know I'm going to tell
you whenever Rock Hudson came to town it
was a big deal so I was a young girl
we'd all go down there and wait for him
he would stay locked up with the guy all
weekend who wouldn't who would go to
Cuba and not go out yeah that's why you
went to Cuba to see the [__] dancing
and the Spanish women and the [__]
madas dancing and [__] Benny morray
singing and you gamble he wouldn't leave
the [__] hotel room yeah and I would
look at my mom and go you know what
you're [__]
crazy you're
crazy she dies 6 years later he's got
AIDS yeah and I'm like [__] lady was
telling telling me the truth yeah
because when they were little girls it
was like when Michael Jackson went to
London and hung his kid outside the
window there was 2,000 people waiting
same thing it's [__] Rock Hudson
You're a Cuban girl you're [__] 12 13
years old and Rock Hudson the biggest
[__] star in American peliculas is
coming to [__] Cuba what's Cuba the
size of Bon yeah everybody knows if
you're coming once you land at the
airport you know Sinatra's in town you
knew yeah so you went down there that's
what happened to the Bay of Pigs you
guys figured it out who the [__] knows
yeah what's up Lee how you feeling dog
we went to Legal Seafood like 18 times
oh you know what I was going to talk I
want to thank Legal Seafoods for [__]
taking good care of
me go ahead oh okay uh that was actually
one of my favorite Parts not just Legal
Seafoods Bill the the bartender I miss
like I miss I'm not even a drinker but I
used my dad always used to take me to
the bar we always used to eat at the bar
sushi bar any bar and I miss guys like
Bill who would just like have like a
regular conver we we we eat up bars a
lot bro he came to our table when we
didn't sit at the bar like he became our
friend I met some great people in Boston
the the star of my world was the hotel
manager Margaret the restaurant manager
yeah she was as beautiful as she was
smart and [__] she was 24 years old
she started there as a bus girl Boston
accent yeah dirty girl yeah dirty Irish
girl but beautiful boyfriend you know
just set one of those girls that you
look at and she'll be married in three
years we just spoke about the
internet and her other business was the
internet that's what she really wanted
that's what she went to college for she
was trying to sell products on there and
we just spoke about that but both
conversations left me [__] like wow
you know finally you meet somebody who's
Dynamite then the bar bill from the
[__] first day I got there my name is
Bill who [__] introduces himself
anymore Oh you mean he was behind the
bar he was behind the bar and he came
right over gave me a menu and put his
hand out [__] guys what 64
265 hands that'll [__] crush your
head bald old yeah you know he don't
need much all he needs is one good
[__] shot to your head and you're
hearing you hearing [__] a Boston Red
Sox game and it's [__] January and
you got like I have to play it's big
puppy yeah you can put a you can put a a
a lipstick on a pig
absolutely you didn't once I see the
lipstick yeah I'm done that's when I
throw the sidekick a de and I run the
[__] out of there and then the cops come
and I tell him he tried to suck my dick
yeah had live no I didn't but you got
lipstick on it's not like you going to
go to a [__] hot dog eting contest
you know what I'm saying they're going
to check your dick for
lipstick see whether not one day I went
to Jiu-Jitsu like two days in a row and
I couldn't walk yeah and I got up that
morning I knew exactly what time it was
I went I dropped Mercy off I got
breakfast I sent some emails and at
11:00 I went over there I walk over
there and every China guy is busy but
the best one over there is the girl
she's like a weightlifter yeah Chinese
weightlifter girl yeah she's strong and
she's very sweet I really like her the
guys are cool too but don't go on
Wednesday she's not there on Wednesdays
and I went in there and I've been going
there and I took my wife there when she
heard a back and now we go together and
it's a great time they got a TV we watch
Law and Order Chinese people love Law
and Order SVU they love it black people
like Red Lobster Chinese people love Law
and Order SVU go to any Chinese
restaurant they got SVU on trying to
figure out the crime or they know it
already they wrote the script you know
what I'm saying these New York cops
they're looking for details they know
exactly who raped abroad there [__]
Chinese people they're Savages you go
down to Chinatown that that's what when
they're really stuck
they take that [__] uh so I go over
there the one day about 2:30 this is
like a like I was high and I was kind of
bored I said let me go get a [__]
massage go do this I had to fly the next
day something and I went over there this
had to
be 100 4 months ago and I went over
there and there was no parking in the
[__] thing and there was no parking
on that street yeah and I was like I'm
[__] so I found parking like a block
away I walked over sure enough come back
in 25 minutes or sit for 25 I go [__]
this and I go I got to be another one of
these that don't want to [__] suck
your dick you know what I'm saying and I
I made it I went down
Lancashire and I made a u-turn I saw
like two of them I went to the Tai one
first and the chick was too Brown for me
like she was something was wrong with
her she had gotten like somebody left
her under the [__] suntanning boot
for 3 days something was wrong with this
CH wait a minute you won't go to a
masseuse because she's too dark as woman
I said the word wrong she was something
was wrong with her oh oh okay something
was wrong with the skin right and Greg
didn't even get up when he saw the dude
she had to be right I know she had to be
no no I said it wrong I'm very sorry if
I insulted anybody she was like those
people that you put under a suntanning
thing yeah and they've been under for 30
years oh like dried out and wrinkled
orange almost it was orange like never
saw anybody that skin color you know and
I went in there and I just smelled the
sperm yeah like had a mild SP smell of
sperm you your creepy look on the face
and I just took a menu I just said look
I want to come back with my wife and I
took a menu okay thank you what time you
open till and I got in the car and I
split and there was one two blocks down
that I've always wanted to check out
uhhuh I've been going to that [__]
haha for nine [__] years and that SP
out there I've heard a thousand creepy
stories but I've also heard that there's
chicks in there that give great [__]
massages yeah I've heard prone C did
they try to give me no no I've heard
both well it took me three minutes to
know I could smell the air of sperm oh
yeah there were two chubby dudes sitting
there waiting to get massages and they
had like an embarrassed look on their
face yeah like somebody would go joy is
that you these guys didn't want me to
know who they were and they didn't want
to know who the [__] I was the lady said
you're like a 30 wait I said I'll be
back ping and that was it my curiosity
was settled yeah if this is a double
door with a lock on it I have friends
between like some bulletproof class yeah
I have friends that go to those things
something's got to be like I don't try
unless you have like condom the whole
sack and around the nuts like the up to
your stomach I found something out what
cuz you know how red band a while ago
said the thing about Saran rap yeah that
they do that because a condom in that
place is like it it show knows what
you're going in there for so they get
charged if you have condoms that's why
they have the ran WRA what do they
charge you with I don't know probably
has to be like yeah her for them I don't
know what it does for yeah it's probably
listen I don't want to I don't want to
nothing nothing with San rap I got a
wife you know I don't want nothing if
you got to put some Ram wrap on there's
a problem with your [__] life you
know what I'm saying well they're going
to suck your dick with saram WAP you're
going to stick it in a hole with saram
WP something is not psychologically
correct with
right I don't know I I see them today I
went and got gas just now yeah I got I
left the house at a quarter two and as I
was pumping gas there's one over there
by my Gulf over there that's my favorite
gas station across from the Mexican Car
Wash across from the potato tacos
Denny's and the [__] massage parl
that massage parl has been there since
day one if you look at it you're like
they've killed people yeah like they've
sent the Chinese mob boss in there and
they've stabbed them in there yeah it's
creepy I've never ever seen a customer
oh is it it's like on the side of the
street there like across the street from
Scientology yeah yeah it's been there
right for 20 years you've never seen you
have to stop there that's the busiest
light in the valley so you always stop
there you look around at the gas station
you look at the Denny's you look at the
potato taco place you look at the car
wash then you look at the massage ball
and go who the [__] would step in there
yeah it's in between like an engine
rotary place and like a [__]
something else it's like a a lawyer or a
travel something crazy and it just says
massage what the [__] thing now what
is Tom mono looking for with this
[__] show what is he looking for I
just I haven't seen it I just saw the
commercial for it he jumps on a desk
he's looking for a p tape yeah and all
the missing tapes yeah I thought he was
looking for the nword tape that's what
from The Apprentice from The Apprentice
all that [__]
what hurts him more the N the nword tape
getting out or the P tape getting out P
tape none that's also true you know the
other day we were talking about
something when we forget as a country is
that we've hated every president the
less since I came from Cuba you
[__] been hating pres yeah all
right you hated Kennedy so much you shot
the
[__] then you impeached Nixon
whatever I mean it I still remember the
night he [__] was on TV I was a kid
and I was crying I really believed in
America how can the pre I didn't
understand Watergate I didn't understand
none of that [__] but we we're always
crying we've never been happier the only
way we're happy is if somebody brings us
we want the president that every day we
wake up and there a check to $20 in the
that's it that's the only President we
want that just puts a 20 in your mailbox
every day unless it's that we're always
going to cry or complain about something
so you're trying to figure out listen
dog if you put the [__] tape on in
here all day
if you just clicked on a tape recorder
in here for a week the things you
hear you mean before the podcast start
before the podcast when I'm myself when
me and Lee sit here at night you could
make millions listening to it yeah but
anybody who listens to it knows that
whatever is said isn't really coming
from the heart first of all you're
dealing 50% with a comedian 50% of our
humor comes from Comedy which comes from
pain when I found my mother on the floor
her arm was purple and I could see that
her by the shoulder it was just like you
got hit with a train purple she had a
massive heart attack I cracked a joke to
myself so why wouldn't I crack a joke
about anything else the most sacred
thing in in a man's life is his mother
and I'll never forget to diffuse that
shock I crack like a [__] joke yeah
like I cracked a joke to myself like
she'll never know I got left back in the
seventh grade I knew it like just stupid
[__] yeah yeah like I said that we got a
things sent to us from Reddit like a
things oh yeah and the guy said that I
made a joke about u a Mexican little boy
crying in a cage and then you should
have seen like 15 people said well joy
forget he's im an immigrant I never
forgot I was an immigrant we're
comedians what we say is the first the F
when you see something Greg fit Simmons
that first voice that you reaction
that's the reaction the audience wants
to hear we just don't have the balls to
say it right I'll never forget
911 911 was on a Tuesday morning and
Monday night I was at the store and Paul
money was on stage and it was the week
that the black guy was going to break
the Home Run Record Barry Bonds Barry
Bonds against the white
dude Mark Maguire was it Sammy SAA no no
no no it was it was was later it was
Mark m why and the white dude going head
tohe and I forget that night he opened
up with they're never going to let that
niggaer break the record like he just
went off on a tangent and he went off on
it so deep that it actually went into my
[__] subconscious okay like they're
never going to let that [__] hit home
run that that's never going to happen
homie they're going to do something to
make up that nigga's whatever you know
return till the next morning I wake up
to my wife going oh my God oh my God my
wife was really like I had just gotten
with her she was overly emotional and
I'm waking up from a cocaine [__]
hangover and I'm seeing the first Tower
go down and I I'll never forget laying
back down go Mooney was right they're
not going to let that [__] break the
Home Run Record cuz it was like on a
Tuesday when he was going to do it that
was the first thought that came to my
head yeah then the second thought was
the Giants didn't cover last night uhhuh
the Giants did not cover the night
before and I go that that's comedy
that's what you wanted he yeah when my
dad died they had a priest come by and
say a few words but he handed out a he
handed out a uh the the prayer on a
piece of paper to everybody like a
little like a little
mlet because they know half the people
are you know we're Irish Catholic but
this there's some there's some of the uh
the other tribes snuck in some of my
dad's friends that were Jewish so they
gave him gave them all a cheat sheet and
we say the prayer and then we're done
the priest goes okay if you could hand
those back into the front again I go I
go he Liv like he died like he lived
sheap and uh and everybody started
laughing and the priest got [__]
pissed and I was like good you should
get
pissed collecting the [__] prayer
back that's the reaction that's the
reaction yeah it's really weird that
that's what comedy is comedy is your
first the first thing you really say to
yourself yeah that's the comedy and then
that thought you're uh your smooth side
whatever that part of your brain comes
in and smoothens out the joke and you
say you talk to yourself out of doing
the joke on stage that night but that
first thing that comes to your mind
that's the joke they want to hear yeah
that takes you a long time cuz you don't
the balls to say it but that's the truth
he kept saying that niggaer ain't going
to hit the Home Run they're never going
to let him hit the Home Run and as soon
as that building got hit with the first
plane that's all I kep thinking about
was he was [__] right cuz it was that
night when he was going to do it that
Tuesday
yeah dude I was on
stage last Thursday night and uh I I did
this joke I had just stupid new joke it
wasn't like anything I thought much
about it's probably not a joke I would
have kept but I just threw it out there
because I had a piece of paper with new
bits written on it and it was Thursday
night there was [__] 12 people there
where was this at The Improv and so I go
uh and the joke was just you know my
nephew's complaining he can't get any
[__] at College you know I said well
don't worry about it I go I go this
thing called the Freshman 15 I go you
find all those girls in the spring
you're good to go and this girl this
woman stands up middle-aged woman [__]
you [__] you with that fat shaming
misogynist to [__] but I mean Joey she
went zero to 60 she didn't she didn't
ramp up it the second I'd finished that
joke she was on her feet screaming the
whole crowd turns around and looks at
her like what the [__] is this a
terrorist attack and the bouncers come
over and I'm throwing gas on the fire
cuz she with her two daughters I'm going
look at mommy getting thrown out the
club I go that I go that's how you burn
calories getting that angry and they
drag her out screaming and I have to I
got to do another 10 minutes and the
whole room is [__] awkward at this
point so I I joke about I'm getting big
laughs but then I still got to
eventually go back to my material and so
I come out
front and I'm standing there talking uh
Owen Smith and a couple other people and
um all of a sudden the woman comes out
out again full head of steam again [__]
you you [__] you're not funny I would
never [__] you like I go what are you
talking about and so I'm standing there
and and I'm going back and forth with
her until I realize she's not de
escalating like her pitch is staying at
10 and I'm not going to stand on a
Melrose in front of the Improv screen
with this crazy lady for any longer so I
turn around I walk away down the street
to go to my car but she's screaming at
the back of my head and I feel like a
[__] like I'm walking away from her all
the comics are watching I'm not even
turning around I'm just beelining back
to my car and so same thing I I uh the
next day it got tagged on some some
social media mine and and she wrote this
[__] letter the daughter wrote this
letter saying that i' I was a misogynist
what I said about her mom and blah blah
blah and blew it all up and then of
course all the comments are like I would
have kicked his ass and all this [__]
like nobody they weren't there they
they're hearing a crazy and so uh yes it
was a whole thing it was a whole thing
what do you think of this thing that's
going on right now well that I could
come out after 36
years and say that you choked me at a
party
or you showed me a dick what the where
are we going with
this where we this is what I was scared
of this is the first time that I I've
okay so now it's not about what we did
two years ago or that I showed you my
dick in a room or nothing like that now
it's something that happened so for 36
years while I was a judge you didn't say
nothing and there's already women
[__] saying no like they don't even
know the whole F nobody knows the whole
story nobody was there well I that I
think that's the scary part is that just
because of the way things are now is
that not that they can't say it but it
everyone immediately goes guilty and you
can't really recover from that so like I
don't have as much of a problem with
them coming out
if he did it if they didn't do it like I
think there should be a punishment if
they didn't do it and have some
repercussions for that but if he did it
I don't have much of a problem with that
but I just it's scary to think about
like someone could just say anything
online and if you get enough people
behind you no no matter what the truth
is people are always going to like I
just saw uh one comic is going to be in
Boston it's pretty coming up and they
said uh coming back after assault
allegations even though it came out that
he didn't like it oh yeah he never was
like that's crazy well here's the
problem is that when there's a movement
there's momentum and people get swept up
into it and that can be used for good
that can be used for bad in this case
obviously it's for good you know this
movement is trying to uh help women see
that they they should be believed when
they come out that we have to not
marginalize them right away but then
people get swept up in that and they
suddenly go oh this is part of that as
opposed to let's judge each case on its
own let's not say oh I'm already riled
up because you know there's been all
these cases that have been proven about
men abusing women so I'm already angry
and now let's grab this guy and put him
in that that same energy as opposed to
let's look at this one individual case
and try to judge it by those merits this
morning I spoke to a friend of mine Joe
Luchi and I met Joe Luchi probably in
the eighth grade and they the
band the area where he lived was the
wildest area in my hometown there's five
or six grandmar schools that grandmar
school by far takes everybody away like
they were doing [__] in the eighth grade
that nobody was doing in the town and
everybody had a catch up over the years
like they were the real deal they had
the field they didn't just have Lincoln
School but they had the field and they
had the Rock Rock and The Rock they were
on the Rocks every night these guys
which meant they were out there drinking
smoking [__] ghetto blasters with
music they were crazy you go down there
at 400 in the morning and find people
like if we live downtown we go let's cut
through 64th Street field you'd find
eight [__] tripping on acid I
mean they were just
deep and uh he goes I'm coming to the
show to see you in West Palm Beach and
I'm bringing my wife he goes should I
bring my daughters what do you you think
and I go uh no I go unless you want them
to know that I Ed in your backyard and
me and started
howling I went to his part like I I was
a junior in high school and I went to
his party like at 6:00 at night his
party started like at 4 in the afternoon
and I got there like at 600 with a
grandma blow I was in high school in
quots but there with a cter of qu luds
that's when I started eating the ones
that people were making at home yeah
which the table of crooked right which
means that the the the the thing leaks
into the bottom ones and these stay weak
yeah so I ate one of the weak ones first
and then I ate the second one and all
our rememberers waking up in an alley at
4 in the morning with drool and puke all
over me and the next day hearing the
stories yeah how are high school kids
allowed to be drinking at I mean
obviously anyways but at 4 P p.m. like
when I did it we tried to hide it his
parents own the bar oh my god oh was
that a bar his parents own the bar so
they was always they were always at the
bar yeah so he would have parties in his
basement that were just legendary but
his legendary parties were where before
concerts so I still remember going to
his house you ready for this Jo luch
August 4th of
1979 they would start at 4 you'd get
there to'd be a keg of beer and there'd
be 12 guys and 12 girls or 20 girls or
whatever the [__]
and people were smoking snorting blow
eating pills and then at about 6:45 we'd
walk to County Boulevard take the bus
into the
City and walk to manad Square Garden
[__]
up [__] up and go watch we went to see
AC DC and Ted and he said all that he
goes that was a rough one he goes I
remember just Angus running through the
audience with on top of whatever's but
then he we all have the same trait he
goes I started doing that Tradition Way
before anybody before concer like meet
at my house at three because the first
party I had was Monday December 6
1976 and he's my age so he had to be
[__] third he was 10 10 13 and he
goes I went to see black Ted Nan open up
for Black Sabbath when he released
free-for-all tour and he goes guess what
else happened that night the Cleveland
Browns beat the whatever in Monday Night
Football I mean that's how good his
memory was yeah but I was just thinking
about how could you judge me from that
night well you can't judge somebody from
what they did 30 years ago or I'd be
under the prison beautiful story
yeah not can I ask you a question yeah
you're a pretty smart guy we love each
other we really do I know what you can
say right now
why the [__] don't I want to go
there I got a call last night from Josh
Wolf well let's start the story straight
the other day I'm watching
TV
and what you we come back we're going to
show you the first new Hollywood
marijuana restaurant
Cafe and uh they flash to it and they
show a bunch of white kids online and
vaporing and they show people inside
haaha and smoking a blunt and they got
high-powered fans and right there and
the foods all got pot in it I don't know
I don't know but right then I knew like
you would never see me close to that
yeah like I knew at that decision last
night I I was talking to Josh Wolf and
he goes have you gone to it yet it's
great and he goes you should go and I go
Josh how long ago I know you you do know
that I would never step foot in that
[__] place you know I've been smoking
dope since I was 12 I got nothing to
prove to know but I got to go down a
restaurant and smoke dope to show these
[__] that I smoke dope the [__] out
of my face and that's all anyone's
talking about is smoking dope every
night it's it's but no back to the why
do I feel this way I mean you're a smart
guy like I sit at home at nights like I
schedule myself because I know I'm at an
age I can't go out two nights in AOW at
the county store it's too much
excitement for me yeah so now Thursday I
got to take a nap so I'd rather go to
the store Tuesday and Thursday and space
it out but when I'm sitting at home
Wednesday it's
8:00 my daughter's going to bed at 8:30
my wife doesn't give a Frenchman's [__]
what I do and I got 20
options and I don't want to do any of
them it's so weird not to offend you you
know I dearly love you I've seen like
pictur from the Fri club and how they
act and Billy Crystal I would stab
myself in the eye after 5 minutes in
there I don't like none of that [__]
yeah you know it's like I still remember
wanting to go to Montreal so bad and
saving up the money and I talk slay to
putting me on during the dirty show and
I took a flight to Detroit when I
checked into the hotel room in Detroit
cuz I was going to go to Montreal in the
morning I was like who the [__] am I to
go there didn't invite me I'm not a part
of those people and even if I go there I
don't want to be there like oh my God
you have such a great time at the bar
yeah it's the same jerk off I could see
on Tuesday at the comedy store right I
just see them now getting drunk in their
in their environment I don't want to I
don't know what it is about me like I do
not want to go there well you're an
outsider that's your that's your
identity is you did it your way and
maybe you weren't embrace by the main
you weren given those same kind of
breaks that somebody else might have
gotten and I don't know why I mean some
people could say it's uh maybe because
people are afraid of you you're you know
you're aggressive on stage you say [__]
nobody else says it's not politically
correct could be racist you know you're
not you're not white and you know
you're I'm I'm not you're a felon do do
is ITW is it an insecurity that I have
or is it a character I've created for me
it feels like like I've always felt this
way I remember the night you came down
and this this might this might have felt
like that environment to you is I was
doing a I do a benefit show every year
for the best buddies we're doing at The
Improv and it was like for whatever
reason I ended up booking I usually book
it because I'm I'm at somebody's house
and they got people over and I think oh
I got to book this [__] thing except
for you who I just call for anytime I do
a benefit I call you straight out of the
gate
and I was there and so it was Zack
alakus and it was Sarah Silverman and I
think it might have been Brian pain so
it was kind of like I think it might
have represented like that kind of Largo
world or that alternative comedy world
that maybe you never felt a part of and
I remember seeing you you didn't come in
the room you were standing in the back
you didn't want to come until you went
on and I think you were feeling like a
little bit trepidacious you know and I
hadn't seen you like that before and you
went on stage and you [__] ripped R
it apart and you were doing the bit
about the chick pissing in your face and
you just didn't give a [__] and I'm
sitting with them in the corner and I'm
curious to see what their reaction is
going to be to you you know because this
is not Largo this is not you know Pro
feminist you know with their use and
they their [__] Jaws were slacked
they were like what what just blew on
stage what [__] storm just settled
over the microphone at the Improv now
and they they [__] loved it they were
like this is
unbelievable and I remember you walking
out and and I I knew that I don't know
that you saw them or how they reacted
but I think you felt really good that
you just did what you do and that
Whatever anxiety you were feeling before
that didn't come on stage with you it
was pure Joey Diaz on that stage well I
always have anxiety yeah you know once I
walk into the Battle Zone yeah the
store the anxiety goes up 150% right
it's like when Michael you know one of
the greatest things about the
Godfather is what what whoever the
director was or whatever the idea he got
when Michael goes into the bathroom
before he shoots to get the gun yeah in
the bronze to
train that
train if I know Greg Fitz Simmons is
sitting in this office
and I got to put a hit on Greg Fitz
Simmons and I have to do it myself at
9:00 at night when he's doing a podcast
with le as I walk up those stairs your
adrenaline goes so high cuz I've been in
that situation before where I rob
somebody or Rob jewelry uh when anytime
I did anything that was that creepy like
robbing the house or robbing a drug
dealer you go
deaf you hear
a like that's all I would hear like your
heart is pounding so much there's so
much adrenaline going into your body
that that's what you hear you kind of
hear a simulation of what Michael heard
on that train Di and I went to the store
my wife made chicken cets for
lunch she went to church she made
chicken colors when she came back I had
like two chicken colorss like 4 or8 two
chicken cuz what do you want for dinner
she gave me the menu for dinner I was
like you know what don't worry about it
I got to go to the store anyway I'll
stop at Joe's Pizza and get dinner I
just get a slice I got I had 14 points
left so I get to The Comedy Store the
other night some dear kid that I've
known for 20 years was talking to me I
really couldn't hear him even with the
hearing aids on I couldn't hear him and
to be honest with you I didn't want to
hear him there's nothing to talk about
when I walked in there was two boxes and
Jo's
Pizza on the piano in the main room I
didn't eat in The Green Room in the
green room I didn't touch him right you
know and I remember going on stage and
getting it over with and then when I
came back I could hear the kid mhm now I
could have a conversation with him right
why are you talking to me right I'm
about to go to war yeah what are you
talking
about and all I could hear he sounded
like Charlie br
and he kept talking until he finally got
it that this guy doesn't want to be
bothered or he's not even hearing me
yeah like I'm going up in the main room
I have no time for small talk right I
don't give a [__] about whatever the
[__] where we met when I go to the I did
a GU spot on your show in St Louis four
years ago and you're supposed to
remember I got to jog my memory about
somebody it's like dude if I if I
remembered you it means you were
memorable if I don't remember you it
let's not rehash something that wasn't
that important in the first place that's
why I hate doing two shows because I
want to talk to the people after the
first show The Crowd but if you have a
second show you really can't yeah cuz
that's an hour of a all sudden it's
[__] Jeopardy right you know it's
Wesley uh do you remember what you said
in episode 274 the Rogan podcast why did
you say this on Greg Fitz Simmons's
podcast just take the picture and shut
your [__] mouth I don't even know
what the [__] I just said on stage and
you want to know what's with the [__]
questions take the [__] picture and
then they get the camera out and the the
the the [__] lock is on the
girlfriend's trying to open it she
doesn't know the code yeah you just
wasted eight minutes with your stupid
[__] question which I have no idea
what you're saying we're in a room with
300 people on the line waiting to take
pictures I got no [__] idea what you
said come over here let me put my armor
around you let me give you a compliment
take a picture let's get the [__] out of
here yeah and then they come back and
they tell you stories I can't [__]
hear you even with the [__] earpiece
I can't [__] hear you there's 300
people in the [__] room so before I
go on like I really like the comedy
store after my little Netflix debacle I
made a decision I'm only going to The
Comedy Store and I have
a like
tonight I love my friends but you know
what leave me [__] alone
Tuesday you don't want to come to the
store on a Tuesday night it's chaos it's
chaos it's two sold do shows in the main
room one in the original room and three
sold out shows in the belly room that's
a total
of 1,200 people in that building not to
mention 100 Comics lurking to suck on
blood or whatever the [__] they do down
there and the staff and the waitresses
you know you want to come down in
[__] Tuesday night and talk I wanted
to bring you a script you know what
Tuesday night's my work night right you
know what I like about Tuesday night
what I told you that night when I called
you when we saw magic that night right I
go in that I get two orders I [__]
get high I take an edible sometimes and
I want to sit in the original room and
watch the three Comics before me and I
want to learn and I don't want to be
bothered guess what I'm get the [__] out
of here with your stupid [__]
questions yeah I'm watching Ali Wong get
the [__] out of here can I watch Ali
Wong is is okay yeah you know I like
when I see you you just sit next to me
we hug each other and we both watch and
laugh right right there's people that
come I never forget one night I'm
sitting there mind in my own business
and somebody bent over and whispered in
my ear who you taking a Charlotte with
you and I just gave him a look like Val
killmer gave that white guy at the diner
and Heat remember when the guys like man
I had to go
[Music]
down
h